hello and welcome to the you're playing
master of puppets yeah so oops no not be
five please yeah playing this line IAM
black against the trump and maybe i
should also check a different line now
and then I mean this is totally fine for
black but just for the sake of variety
could be interesting to play something
else okay interesting my way of playing
this with age three okay take it yeah
maybe with g6 Bishop g7 it's a somewhat
slower set up here for what I told
define one I mean white is totally okay
but still a little bit and on there on
the slow side mmm we should age 60 hmm
hmm Bishop age 6 is a bit of bit
annoying him he threatens a queen g5
after Bishop age 6 hmm 94 he might take
right wow that's not very nice
hmm okay
re uncomfortable Quincy five Wow
whoa that's really bad cannot do ecig
senior many moves are not playable at
all King edge 80 will take black wins e5
yeah wow it looks very very tough
I can maybe I'm okay now I don't see a
direct way him to to kill me ok now i
should be ok and he's six k z6 yeah I
wonder if he had something more powerful
I didn't like my position at all
Knight f3 at night h5 and I've thought
but he doesn't agree it seems still
think I have this move and Oh didn't see
Knight f6 yeah oh well that's bad right
f4 night of Seven Kings chase takes pawn
down at the end Jesus ok
Jim what can you do I guess he played it
quite nicely spotted all the door things
that I didn't see hmm can I how do i get
something going here i wonder if he five
if I five is a move on if I should maybe
get this over
now let h 5 is P is a possibility maybe
no you just straps stuff here amazing
what am I doing here in this game
haha what did whatever what a bad game
not seeing anything check Jim it's very
little to hope for him hi morning okay
dry Thompson's resign Wow a bad game a
bad game yeah I really did the big issue
was this Bishop age six stuff I really
was under severe pressure there and took
a long time to figure something out this
I think is the best probably yeah now
I'm just okay of course this is so so
slow what is doing I shouldn't be in any
trouble but I got myself into travel
again and I u6 the engine wants to do
this so says I'm already clearly better
which I don't quite get this thing yeah
night h5 is a threat this is what the
engine gives do so hey good he has two
very weird night suit okay well what I
did cannot be bad she thought that I
should have an advantage here simply
with this stupid night and so on but I
didn't see I didn't play it well simply
this is maybe even questionable already
and and this is yeah I just blundered
night x g5 is what it is I thought I'm
just better after nine th five but he
has star takes g5 I have to go back now
okay I put something here it's nice
nothing special yeah idea i blundered i
blundered this and I just displayed it
very badly
strombel TI basically blundered the rook
loss it but I don't have anything up his
his totally solid him and they have no
threats yeah quite a bad game thanks for
watching